hey guys it is Friday my name is just as
with old days and you're looking that
Nijo I make thanks so much for doing
that first up Mortal Kombat X fans can
enjoy a massive update which lands at
this week alongside the release of the
pc version of mortal kombat x l came a
huge patch that's made a ton of balance
changes the higher and lower tier
characters have been brought far more in
line with one another to ensure the
experience is more balanced and fun
develop another round revealed that all
of the in-game items that were
previously only available to those
playing the mobile game are now free to
everyone the patch is also implemented
adjustments to the cost of energy
running impacts air attacks and a whole
lot of minor changes and fixes for every
character on the roster you can check
out all those details in a story on site
the Elder Scrolls online also got a big
update this week which will let you
freely roam the game world the one
Tamriel feature which was shown off at
e3 lets you explore the entire game
world and everywhere you visit scales to
the level of your character once you're
done with the tutorial you're free to
venture for you can also now group up
with anyone regardless of the Alliance
you chose upon creating a character
which should make finding pals much
easier the patch is also enabling
jeweling outside serial standardizing
loot across zones and implementing zone
redesigns for a mix of solo and group
play we've improved bosses and
standardized difficulty the update is
available on PC now and will be coming
to ps4 and xbox one on October 18 in
news it seems to have frustrated some of
you you will need to have the call of
duty infinite warfare disc inserted if
you want to play modern warfare
remastered modern warfare ii mustard is
a digital-only game that is only
available through infinite warfare
premium editions having the infinite
warfare disconcerted only applies to
those of you who patches infinite
warfare on a physical disc of course but
if you fall into that category you will
need to keep it in your console if you
want to play modern warfare remastered
if you buy the legacy edition of
infinite warfare digitally on steen PSN
or Xbox Live you'll get access to both
infinite warfare and modern warfare
remastered Microsoft have revealed Gears
of War for bonuses for players the
previous games in the series if you've
played any gears game and you're an xbox
live gold or silver subscriber you'll
get a legacy emblem called first wave
you can pick up the emblem in Gears
fourth customization menu to qualify
you'll just need to have played any
previous gift game while connected to
xbox live he'll also be gifted and
operations pack with at least one
customization item and for cards the
codes for the operations packs are going
out now so keep an eye on your inbox
finally this week more details about
horizon zero dawn arrived here's the
latest game informer has reported that
the post-apocalyptic open-world action
game will feature side quests and
activities to complete in addition to
the main storyline horizon will include
areas called corruption zones that you
can clear out to gain experience and
make hunting and exploring easier
speaking of which it sounds like hunting
and crafting will keep you super busy
and completing hunting challenges will
grant you access to a hunters guild
where you can climb the ranks you can
also learn about the tribes equal
horizons world home by completing their
specific quests this week on site we
talked about what other games are on
their way before the years out check out
what's coming in mafia 3 and help you
decide which vr headset is right for you
that is everything I've got for you this
week do let me know what you cared about
down in that comment box and I will see
you again on Monday